let's do a podcast do I want to start
this podcast guy it's Monday it's Monday
and I like how you're bobbing back and
forth and I yep let's do it let's do it
let's do it do it do it this is gonna
catch on let's do it
people are gonna start using this let's
do it's really it sounds like let's do
it do it would do it we're gonna swoop
it I'll whip it well make it we'll make
it well I feel like Alan seen you in
seven weeks twist it up and twist it
yeah you had a dick like a wristwatch I
want to I want to I want to I just want
to say that I'm my weekend was kind of
ruined why
well you because you now know yes
because I got a very nice message I was
just I was sitting there hanging out and
it was nice it was like oh yeah I was
just this here was I go in Utah bright
gray Club about to go onstage I go yep
and then I got what are you so what are
you doing that's all I got I went huh
it's funny he wants to play I go I click
on it where were you that when you
clicked on those pictures though I was
right and I was with my in-laws and my
kids in fact I looked at my son's face
my son's face was in my beautiful son
who I could like might you know the
light of my life and then I went to my
phone and I saw an upshot I want you to
think about if you're about to take a
piss I don't think you even unzipped you
just pulled your balls and your [ __ ] out
of the pants lazy but even open your
thing you herniated it out so it's it's
prosecute to the balls look like like
somebody took a rope and tied you at the
base cuz they can't if they could talk
they'd be going
they look so like honest warts fingers
faith I've told oh Rico yup and I'm said
this is again the camera was held
underneath his balls in his nose and I
see yep and I see this shitty lazy no
say it impossible fact
won't I like the girth I'm a girl dude
but it's just it's sitting there heavy
and boards want to hit you with
something bro and you gotta know who
drips to pee to drip drip before I even
shut up so [ __ ] you're bothering me
lately bear and all I could write was oh
no that's all your own oh and I didn't
look at my phone again
so you that I can see that a me - oh no
you matured me I'm a - dhimmitude mate
sorry man I felt like you asked for it
like you wanted and then I went to my
phone again and my mother-in-law was
there and she's and I and I hit that and
I I was like she might have seen that
everyone see my dick now family well
that's not cool bro you're the one I did
it I sent it expecting me to be cool
about it bro it's funny how you wouldn't
want people to see your dong from
certain angles it's like this guy comic
I knew there's a there's a real skill to
take into this comic I knew said he goes
I was on a roller coaster with this girl
I was dating and the roller coaster kind
of went up and I saw her face from a
certain angle and I wasn't attracted to
her father certain age as you see people
were like yeah also when you get older
you had a double chin girl well when you
get older also you start to see people
you've known a long time including
yourself you see an angle and you go oh
you gettin old oh dude father time due
to some of my buddies don't hurt
defenseless I won't say where I know
more how long I've known him but known
for a while
they sent me pictures like dude how
could you miss this they sent me the
pictures like well that's clearly why I
missed it
y'all look like [ __ ] no everyone stop
working out yeah everyone doesn't god
damn father time just took your face put
it the [ __ ] life grinder and well you
know those guys who they they let
themselves go that could that thing I
just love I don't have time to work out
yeah well I'm not saying I work out
because I'm vain I mean I'm not saying I
work out cuz I'm discipline I work out
because I'm vain and insecure so yeah
and you like it - yeah I like feeling
better but there's some people that just
go high schools done you over time stop
moving I told you when I was in the
that sound was in Denver at the shopping
like whatever King Soopers [ __ ]
they got in Denver I'm walking around I
see this guy keep looking at me I'm like
God matching sweatsuits a terrible look
dude and he kept falling around it's
like you little weasel cease date
through the sweat buddy they were too
small and they got and he's here he had
literally like the bird's nest here and
he kept staring me fall me I was like
all right and I'll see a fan but
completely wants to jack off on me and
so I keep walking I go down the frozen
for food aisle and then I see him right
behind my turn I go what's up man what's
up bro what's up man he goes come on I'm
like excuse me us come on dude you still
you got so big time you'll recognize
your boy from high school like oh oh my
god wow possessed by the ugly devil not
just he didn't age well oh my god I mean
start in high school yes just uh got all
the girls captain on lacrosse team
[ __ ] good-looking dude smart big and
then oh my dude I was like I'll tell you
what age did you every option in your
life go wrong like did everything break
well when I was 40 I got married where
for maybe forty one I got married and I
had my wedding I had my wedding and I
had people come in from all over I'll
tell you what age is he like nobody's
business is tobacco you have some of
those red alcohol that have been smoking
forever and drinking yeah Wow
stress though big time yes is a huge get
the president's like Obama is White
House picture he's all and then after
he's all like [ __ ] fifteen years
older stress is impressive get you well
you I'm a hypochondriac you're not a
hypochondriac right I am yeah you are
you get a spot in anything gets cancer
yeah or I get like a muscle twitch and
I'm like muscle don't ever Google
symptoms no cuz when you google symptoms
you go
I got a muscle twitch then you start
thinking about your muscles twitching
and then you go there's one of my back
don't be and then I go all I have ALS I
call my friends in neurologist he goes
before you ask me you don't have ALS
yeah okay thinks it's not how it works
my
new you just go to your twitching
muscles every I don't care if it's all
over your body this is not how it works
as I was telling chin on the show
earlier today in long story short
tiger's been having these like these the
shooting pains in his head and I like
freaked out just for a second and then
stop and so that happened then I said
we're gonna rushed from the emergency
room and then you know it did happen for
a little bit of time then in between my
shows on Saturday night Joanna calls me
and she's like hey can you talk he don't
he shows like no what's up I know she
puts can you talk about serious so she I
have 20 minutes before my next show I go
what's up like she's like crying sake
tiger had another one of his moments we
take him out of the bath and we're
rushing the mushroom right now so I'm
Michael [ __ ] and I look at Keith the
owner of wise guys I'm like how long do
I have because you have 20 minutes I'm
like alright so I go into the [ __ ]
green room emotionless fog crying Jay
comes back there I tell what's going on
and so I tell Jan like Kate showed
Joanna and her mom didn't have service
cuz we go in the hospital there's no
service so I go as soon as you hear some
come to the middle where I can't see you
I'm be in the middle of my set and just
waved the phone like this so I know
Tigers okay Jay never comes some 40
minutes and my fingers wrap it I just
kind of Flint didn't give a bad joke did
my do my job yet did a shorter set and
rush to the back yeah he did a cat-scan
he did all the vitals okay
he's mean he did they think it's up
called an ice pick headache where it's a
shooting pain for its Lily he freaks out
for second so then it's gone okay he's
going weird I'm taking their ice pick
hey kenick I'm taking her he's going to
neurologist today okay but he did he did
he did the gas man
but everything's okay yeah and then then
they're all just gonna see what exactly
is causing it and we can try and fix it
okay you could grow out tell you what
man in between shows I'm usually good oh
you mean you don't feel funny when your
kids having shooting pains in his head
that's crazy oh you know when you're
when your precious little child no it's
fun though is when you're in Utah so
you're completely helpless and then what
makes it even better is I'm like you
know what I'm just gonna google what it
could be well that was
now you don't go you never googled of
course the level-headed J but he's like
nope this is what I bet you a nice big
headaches or go through all the sides
yeah because um yeah that's a good time
yeah I can't even see my kid I saw my
daughter get an injection and she
started to cry so I couldn't be at the
hospital I can't I can't do it I I'm not
I'm not strong that way me neither I get
upset I want to hurt the doctor he's
only trying to help I talk [ __ ] to them
it's not good
no so I'm bringing the neurologist but I
just stay outside I don't do well yeah
or I'll argue with them to say something
no come on this fight you're talking
about what's the odds yeah give me odds
it's not good I stay away from it no
it's it's it's a tough oh my friend had
um a bad skin cancer diagnosis and had
to take up like a lot of pieces of his
you know he's okay but its face and
stuffing and it was bad but he was they
would tell him something and he'd go no
actually there are other options and
they were like no and he goes no there
are I'll show you and he was just he's
like how do you know that he's like well
there's something called YouTube and
Google there are a lot of people have
gone through this that give you
information Rosa you can know everything
well you can also know you can do a
search for yeah yeah for sure so it's
pretty interesting but wise guys it's
fun though everyone kept asking for you
really yeah damnit he's the best
nice crooner he's gay that's a great you
know sports like a [ __ ] is he
really oh dude his his brother was on
fence Grenet alabama what yeah I didn't
know that brother was all over the the
college circuit all over big-time
schools I went to tell me now I'm like
holy [ __ ] then we had because you know
the Dodgers were playing you Saul jazz
were playing there was cultural bond so
he had three TVs on for me Wow
me and Jay and him could just watch all
the game Jay knows yeah the [ __ ]
it was fun though man just keep those
swartz oh yeah talk to me he's a great
guy oh he's a great guy good guys guys
yeah he's a guys comics too it's like
he's the best he's the best I asked you
know he's been doing for a while his
wife from that the wise guys in Salt
Lake and Provo they just run it together
wife runs Provo here in Salt Lake City
to be an offensive coordinator it's
interesting cuz talking to you about
four books I didn't know anything about
it like the details monster you have to
be I mean you have to it's it's it's
terrible job it's a terrible job cuz you
it's 16 hours a day right now you can't
put enough time now
there's no offseason in college you got
to recruit kids and god I would not want
that job now you gotta love it EEP ah my
god eat sleep I always thought it was
interesting I knew I didn't ever want to
be a coach at that level but I for sure
knew I didn't want to do it because when
we're in training camp we'd have
training table and was that like 7
o'clock at night after that long last
day and the coaches would be there
eating with us with their families
that's the only time they've seen their
families so it's like damn like god this
really may be like little babies and
toddlers and there would be yeah but
worse
well herb and Meyer said something to
the effect of if you're gonna come come
with tell me when you come and do
stand-up so I can come and he said but
if it's in and he gave me like a Puri
Lindo a window like he but he said he
gave me like a 7 month window where he
goes anytime there I can't I go you can
come out for a night he goes yeah yeah
that's why I don't that's that is the
only reason I don't coach I see I'm glad
someone talk to you out of it
yeah no I got a thing for you yeah can
you name the top three gayest cities in
America who the top 3 gayest man from
first for Kappa obviously San Francisco
so was San Fran number one yeah San
Francisco was always the place that you
went to with your blood yes well because
it was big you remember what was the one
thing politically so now now political
you're politically liable if you me to
someone or something like that but
always in the 50s and the 60s in this
country what they threaten you with when
you're a politician what were the rumors
you're asexual and being a homosexual
the movie milk yes being a homosexual in
this country in the 50s 60s and even 70s
and 80s screw you over
well it was political death you wouldn't
ever be gay and today even today even
today I'm a gay politician ain't go name
a gay actor you couldn't be a gay actor
give him space he will suck dick but he
but Kevin was gay forever and nobody I
knew it because I knew guys who followed
them yeah but but but but he I do but he
all right man that guy's name is
and but but but but but I remember going
he is cuz I've been watching the months
me - I was shocked everything else I see
what kept it a secret you didn't come
out until this whole thinking there's a
few I've heard yeah yeah but because
Hollywood oh it would always say you
can't you know it's it's all so crazy if
you don't think Hugh Jackman will jack
you off with you I think he might be
straight even though I did watch the
Tyson fight with him and the guys with
he was with were beautiful and they were
they you don't sing and dance like that
and not suck a dick in your life then
I'm not gonna respond I don't know but
I'm here to crush your dreams
Wolverine suck you off oh boy then kill
you can't confirm her all right yeah but
back in the day so you couldn't be gay
and if you were Jewish in this country
you changed your name to what mostly
Miller well Miller and if you look at
the old gangster movies like The
Godfather and all that big offal is the
exception but almost all the old
gangster movies they were Jews they're
all Jews oh yeah thank you thank you
they're all Jews but you could you would
change your name if you're in Hollywood
you wouldn't you weren't a Jewish actor
so to go back to it you so San Francisco
number one okay so San Francisco hold on
hold on New York City I got to go with
New York City hold on I'm gonna say it
Atlanta oh wow
yeah that's racist number one Salt Lake
City well that's because they're Mormon
and they know how do you know that did
the I didn't do all the comments in the
back in the green we're like yeah you
know it's the gay city I'm like get the
[ __ ] out of her Kappa it is you got
voted gave City I mean well this is it
might be like what guys coming in with
this this is gay there's no drinking I
mean it might be that maybe a bunch of
guys are saying that no bro let's see
cuz I'm calling [ __ ] I I do I didn't
believe it either and they're like it's
number one I'm calling [ __ ] cuz all
your friends in the back no no but that
mean Jay looked it up the gates in
America
me and chin looked it up too ok cities
hmm main this is a different one
my computer's not responding right now
but um yeah they get the highest rate of
same-sex couples that's a good one but
you can't get married in youth all right
can you don't think so cuz that would be
that probably la if it's not I think gay
marriage is legal in discussed go Santa
Rosa California but the most gay people
per capita is in Salt Lake City just
fried more days in San Fran but per
capita city I was blown away I had no
idea that's crazy
hmm but I would say San Fran umber one
yeah Hollywood number two Hollywood a
certain area of hollywood west hollywood
yeah you know and then worthy where the
bar the white swallow is you know that's
a bar right but it's a you know it
swallows a bird a bird white swallow
here's a little drop of knowledge on yes
you know what sailors would get
swallowed tattoos of the bird you know
on their neck forearms gay
no no bro they would get it after they
Oh
Salt Lake City named KS us City yeah
come on
but you could only get a swallow tattoo
if you did 5,000 nautical miles at sea
so if you gots walked out with a bunch
of swallows he's a badass a oh now you
know the [ __ ] kids get them and they
don't so you were out to stick your lap
in the pool and they [ __ ] get smaller
tattoos I've never understood people who
love the sea I love this it terrifies me
till I say I love the sea I've spent a
lot of time on boats or nothing like
that I love the ocean if I spend I spend
about three minutes on a boat and
there's couple waves like it's it's
super fast I get sick on on yards on uh
on cruises no yeah I'm not a cruise guy
all the cruise is a big-ass hotel yeah
uncie that's right used to be a whole
lot of [ __ ] that went on on cruises
you know still is a whole lot of [ __ ]
our cameras everywhere so you can't
follow back hey you could bang the stuff
you can still [ __ ] the stuff you clean
it up they can't know if they get it
never been on the kid rock tour then a
zone cruise ship and everyone just [ __ ]
really I've know something about it's
not about being on the high seas it's
this guy in the video and just finally
it's time to let yourself loose and fun
we had a waiter who was from Serbia who
couldn't be better-looking and my whole
family were all there and this guy this
was
my old girlfriend and this guy would
come up and go Tigers Tigers listen to
me a tiger so I have I have a lot of
things for you Tigers and he would he
would give you your your your you know
the specials of the day yeah so Tigers
you have to listen to me otherwise I'm
gonna have to get out of here and he was
just one of those guys and he had sex
with all the girls all the videos may as
well cuz she was like haha it's so funny
how does he that tall handsome is [ __ ]
he said he had sex with all the girls
every every dancer has had such a seedy
spread bro those sailors at seas and
then go into port deport you know it's
funny about that your old dirtbag friend
when he was about around 28 or whatever
I was I was on cruise with my dear
friend Jim Burke and I hooked up with a
beautiful she wasn't but she had a great
body face could stop a clock in fact if
I was she had a great body and she was
wonderful and we we hooked up in a
doorway of I believe the town of town in
Bermuda you know Bermuda okay I think
that's where it was don't hold me to the
details okay I'm ago and my friend sue
my Jimmy kept going enjoy enjoy because
she doesn't have sex with guys all the
time like that and throw the herpes that
you're definitely in here and head for
my mom I checked my dick honestly I get
a little thing everybody I have our base
oh no [ __ ] the hyper contract that I
was true though I mean think about she's
seen all sorts of dicks from all over
the world news economist what I'm trying
to say yeah they're gonna catch some
well I was right in the doorway bird flu
on your dick something dude he's like
I'm sure she never does that dude but
you could have anything forever he
doesn't you could cat you could have
anything from anywhere because you're on
the high seas I'm sure there isn't a
constant rotation of dudes and she
hasn't said sex with every guy on the
boat Reina [ __ ] I drank from the
communal cup dude have you ever have you
ever seen that scene in a lord of war
Nicolas Cage he flies to Africa they try
[ __ ] him over and he gets his room
it's just too smoking hot black girls in
his room no like all girls I mean put
the odds of them having like hiv/aids
it's like 95 percent and he's like is
there any condoms like no we don't use
condoms there
they're trying to entice um he's like
get the [ __ ] out it was like this close
yeah now you got I don't have to do and
no don't roll the dice I'll dude come on
my dick goes now we'll figure it out
forget magic Joe and I run and I go no
no my dick would go he's fine magics
fine you'll be fine dude look how hot
they are we'll figure out tomorrow
morning
that's the dick talking yeah they are
like he walks in his room and they talk
about how high the AIDS statistics are
look at those two Buhari gorgeous you're
not busted ass room the nicest ruined
Africa that's a great scene that I
remember this scene oh it's a great was
Nick Cage oh they're there they're
simply perfect
yeah look at them I'm gonna have to risk
it all dude aids and all bro we're gonna
figure out the cocktail tomorrow morning
Brendan and I come and I go Brandon
don't and then I talk you let me take
one for the fall I'm old and age doesn't
affect through having AIDS I'm getting
you know dude my bros you have your
whole life let me get in there no new
shirts aid bros come on let me get in
there
curls if these pubes look a little bit
gray sometimes that's blond hair I
promise look at all this rub and all up
on you I'd be screwed dude I become on
display bruh alright we'll figure out
tomorrow let's just get through this now
think about if you did decide to go down
that road as soon as you bust that nut
you'd be like oh my [ __ ] garlic drink
I'm in Slater you go next mm-hm
i'ma say you go oh yeah next I got next
[ __ ] and you go ahead and grab
your dick very clean because that's why
it works maybe for thank-you days off
and then you will go to work that's
right it everybody knows that you just
take a shower in your fine god only it
was that I love I love [ __ ] my buddy
you don't dude don't worry about good
chlamydia gonorrhea just pee if you pee
right after okay bro say oh nice house
on our side that's like in Denver there
was this kid he's a phenomenal jutsu guy
barely spoken English ridiculous body
just a dime piece he hooked up with just
this salute of the Denver community who
was he where is he from Brazil barely
spoken English but he's well he hooked
up with this white girl who jaws
loved all the dick yes there's nothing
wrong with that that's just what she
liked dicks with her thing and she
sucked everybody off and slept with
everybody really how it was her thing
yeah and that's what she that's where I
call that my kind of girl
yeah so yes I'm do and then some call
that a good citizen I don't like the
word [ __ ] I mean II think the word
enthusiastic adventurous and open mind
and open mind let's say she was very
open-minded every dick ever of all time
so so she hooked up with this kid who
fresh off the boat from Brazil speaks
zero English and he had sex with her
without a condom and when we went dude
what the [ __ ] you doing he goes don't
worry and it's horrible broken English
[ __ ] analyst I took a shower wash it
off right after what okay that works
yeah that works there you go there
you'll be fine and then also she won't
get by we go where'd you bus he was
inside of it well perfect so he goes but
don't worry she said she squirted Alan
again again dude I like where your
head's at this is great thinking you're
a young man not that young should be a
little more educated but we're gonna be
best for the doubt
all you know is jujitsu so when you went
to the bathroom and wash your dick with
water doesn't work I love those macho
guys just seen his face when people told
him he's like what the [ __ ] I'm immune
yeah no idea that you do apparently some
people do have mmm immunity to an extent
to chlamydia gonorrhea things like that
apparently not to pregnancy not to Pat
not to child support I'll say whoever
has to ever worry about HIV or its STDs
ever is a man who's never even been
kicked in the nuts that beach in yeah
yeah I mean off to worry about STDs bro
okay cutting heads off I've never had
lunches Wow
yeah I'm working freaking paranoid I
have you really I sure have yeah the
years that I spent being a [ __ ]
scumbag I mean yeah because you did do
it every young man you're like I don't
what I mean I you know you're like hey
you never had that kind of I always have
a condom no matter what you got going on
you right now right now are you that
guy's wallet like your [ __ ] the night I
used to carry my wallet
that's smart no after a while gets me so
then you just put in your pocket but
then the girls like
like my condom when you're younger he's
just you know yummy new car chin just
gay something pops off the case you
never know yeah oh yeah I did you know
when I was younger
what I was like roll the dice dude and
then there's anything more awkward than
you buy condoms at the [ __ ]
convenience store of the [ __ ] grocery
store thank god they're self checked out
I know it's pretty when I have to get
the extra large
I think it's self checkout Connors I
think that I'm wondering glass no not
not anymore not condoms I'm serious no
I'm serious condoms are straight-up you
know what will not sell you know what I
always do when I was young I I got the
magnums and then I would grab my bazooka
Joe's bubble gum and like a [ __ ] slap
at it oh yeah I'd be grabbed like a
slinky and then I would I was sling I
grab a slinky I would pass him I would
go I'd give the calms first and before
you saying they go every dude slinkys
where am i right just change the subject
that's right that's right I'm just wring
the thing because I don't want to be
like dude come on
yeah well you're practicing safe sex you
know you know what cells are they made a
lot of crazy in the Galaga countries
when you sell small medium large condoms
which they have you will never the
marketing things in the United States
and nobody's buying small nobody-nobody
small they got medium either you buy
condoms even guys are size 6 shoes
anybody then there's Magnum which was
genius and which of course I would I
don't care if I'm working with like a
your thumb I'm getting all my mag and
then they had the extra large which
Magnum XL I don't need no I'm not fist
pumping bro that's all we buy no that's
not true but from God skill break yeah I
can't I want to show that but I can't I
want to live there guys well you watch
any porn guys yeah you're watched
black.com
sorry I said those guys are working with
that's like looking at a monster with a
tail I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
yes god bless those guys wait your
muscular good-looking and you got that
piece all right
Congrats
sorry that's Kanye's favorite website
black yeah black.com when I heard him
say that I was like I know what he's
talking about
oh yeah chin what'd you do this weekend
dude um videos there's more videos of
your victims or victims yeah no you
can't tape the video ah let me see the
video post now man come on dude let us
see it try and get views bro I've seen a
thing Drake I know what you doing put it
on for Brian let Brian critique your
singing I wasn't happy about this one
either though I love you then why'd you
post it cuz I felt like I needed to get
some creative energy uh oh yeah done
mean you have to post it now how many
takes did you do before you did this
that's the thing I didn't do if you
don't want your own goddamn YouTube holy
[ __ ]
there it is um there
oh I follow you why don't I watch this I
don't know but then this is like a lot
of random stuff that I do here too oh
that I'm not the bad dog to set up I got
a couch okay finally you did a [ __ ]
currant Jam I refused to do you heard
that you know the song right no Greg you
will no you never heard the song like
your view though
yeah
any motion
[Music]
you have a great voice thanks man you're
legit it to get man take it easy
[Music]
still no one doesn't not like it chin
the count of 27 like zero dislike as
soon as you say that they're gonna start
now you more rights how do you how do
you argue with the voice I don't know
now let me hear the original that's good
type enhance oh I just do Drake coming
home now let me play the original for
you I'm not saying chins not very good
but let's hear the original you want the
video or the Justin song the value it's
a long video oh you give a [ __ ] if he
saw her oh she's being kidnapped I
cannot stop listening to Drake's new
song with Travis Scott sicko what is it
sick of trying to educate your old ass I
know I mean now let's compare him to
chin right it's Jake the shitty look
very easy to break the [ __ ] you just see
he gonna [ __ ] I won't drink that [ __ ]
yes some battle
I'm here to do it live yeah what do you
think he's amazing you ain't not Drake
right no I'm not I'm not actually more
of a fan of his than I am of you oh I
mean I I mean he's great but by the way
I didn't know his voice was so high
doesn't he have a low voice doesn't he
rap when he talks he sounds it is lower
right let's check in my life on Ellen
please welcome Drake
featuring maggid Jordan do you know who
my G joiners I didn't know that he'll
kill my teen I was on the song got my
mind on hold on B let's hear this dude
cuz you can't I get [ __ ] who is out
[Music]
[Music]
all right so maybe you had an offline on
Ellen we can go to the list of all right
thanks Jimmy here that let me hear that
song you're Drake row you're easy he's
just as good
listen to Brian bro sorry Night Live's
was your honor with that song yeah no
he's outside live with another I want to
hear the song you're like oh all right
hon let me show - then I'll uh just
drink yes or no yeah Drake yes - no I
got my mind on you no no my turn I got
mine oh yeah don't you watch how awkward
this is the top one yeah the top 100
sure what just because it's song you
please stop singing for me I think this
is it he's like in this box yeah okay
this is awkward
imagine me - all by yourself doing this
that's not a weird I would have some toe
okay so it's not great live but no Han
wait it gets awkward cuz there comes
like this like like there's a reggae
vibe and then he's just like I gotta see
that yeah get ready it's an awkward
perform times you know it just forms as
a cringe-worthy and you tonight it's not
his fault I saw he's still my favorite
but this was tough I was watching this
live like see he doesn't speak to me but
I appreciate he's my favorite see this
part of us this is a part of his appeal
though yeah I love that he's dorky yeah
yeah as an actors yes yeah he's not
trying to be hard he sings in she's a
real he's a real like twenty clowns
people you you just got bodied by a
singing yeah he Dyke so he's a silly
goose a little bit no I'll bring up the
side with Will Ferrell where they cut
guys and they have their hand shakes I
post on my Instagram haha oh dude for
this might be one of the greatest I live
[ __ ] skits ever but it was on that
super top secret NBA training so far we
brought in a few experts to work on your
lunges a shake this is coach Murphy and
coach Palmer coaches all right guys
we've seen a lot of great plays from you
today but your dog crap coach Murph is
right obviously listen after after I ok
the crowd wants to see you shaking hands
right yeah they want to know you're
really friends best that's right
that's friends from the same
neighborhood okay starting today if you
spell but your handshake sucks we will
trade you absolutely that's ridiculous
usually what this means talking mark
mouth over smart mouth what's your name
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow okay tomorrow
tomorrow I said the less I like it
he the real plan I want to take notes
this first one's called the Jenga
there's a block hello more block every
one more one more
Oh Oh Jenga all right next up coach I
think we're going gossip Queen this is
one of our most okay tall ones the prom
can't maintain a nice firm grip in the
hips bro look at Drake space might want
to take a picture the last lifetime
SoDo alright yo should we be getting
back on defense defense is that your
cousin Jamar next one here a little on
the controversial side but this one's
called black dad that's right that's
right all right
complicated it takes a lot of practice
yo well I'll be able to do that up
tomorrow didn't know so that was on T
and ferry where they did the ferry
all-star game how funny it's great he's
Jake who's an actor that he came from
these like childhood actor it's really
cool Mary yes yep I don't know how we
got started on that oh we're talking
about Drake yeah yeah that's him as a
little kid he's great on Saturday Night
Live frosty amazing yeah lifetime
performer on school that I work with
Brett Dyer who was on Jane diversion for
five years he's 28
reminds me of yet like a young Bradley
Cooper he's so good and so funny and I'm
like there is he's so [ __ ] good and I
watch him and he makes everything
funniest [ __ ] and you go wonder why so
good oh well he's been acting since he
was I don't know eight I don't know he's
been doing it for 14 [ __ ] years I get
everything he does is like unbelievable
and again it's like any time you see
these young these young people that are
working like that they've been doing it
forever it's like sometimes yeah but
they're like you think you're then get
your wild card who has no background yes
but I'm saying but guys like this can do
pretty much anything whether it's drama
comedy they can just do it all oh they
can also dance and they can sing they
all did you don't watch Breakfast Club
but Jay and I and Utah watching Jonah
Hill on Breakfast Club
so he's trying you what Charlie hell I'm
Breakfast Club you definitely want
what's good actor okay he was trying so
hard to be cooled them it was so
embarrassed what is Breakfast Club oh
well you tried so hard to be like AI
know rappers I like black people and it
was so awkward to me he's like I'm such
a fan like I'm a hip-hop fan I know my
hip-hop and just keep like listen out
hip-hop guys there's like god damn dude
just be yourself just be your [ __ ]
self doing a great actor yeah he has a
movie coming out soon too about his I
forget what the movie is Gate 41 yeah
about the 90s kids are kid than
something in the night Charlotte man
he's
smart I've listened to a lot of him talk
yeah barracks club my favorite radio for
sure friends now radio yeah they're
great on there yeah but uh yeah Jonah
Hill was like I'm hip I'm cool I like
black people and it's so obvious only
god damn dude take it down a notch yeah
take it down I'll tell what's gonna be
fun Brian flip conversations I have a
5:45 a.m. call time tomorrow because I'm
have a car pick me up and take me to Big
Bear I'm gonna spend all day and night
with Tyson Fury you know and there's
nobody there's nothing I'd like more to
watch than to watch that training camp
but if I do I won't do it meet up 540
I've had that I can't do I can't do that
to our drive to Big Bear yes I would
drive myself far as big I don't want to
drive this I've done how far is a whiny
Drive Bubba it's prior luck from here
three two and a half three hours to
enough let me say just google it no
because I got there and I thinking Aaron
that my daughter got super carsick when
she was a little girl I took her up
there to meet Will Sasso and Friends I
walked two hours no traffic so I leave
that six yeah yummy good man Wow
Waze will actually tell you no you don't
deal I don't like I don't [ __ ] with
laziness you're not enjoying your not
going on you're going though I'm have
someone drive me to you I'm not taking
my [ __ ] gt3rs
cuz the snow and [ __ ] yeah is there snow
right now yeah really freezing outside
dude it's cold in the mornings up there
have you ever been big bear cat no cat
what'd you do this weekend um I went to
go back to Little Tokyo where I used to
live and I went to go eat ramen bother
than that just work you're working on
stop huh
yeah where are you working I work at a
I'm not gonna say that I'm constantly
telling where your work is yeah I'm
concierge at somewhere that's very
bougie yeah yeah really I work with a
lot of very eccentric millionaires
really yeah how about so many people are
asking for cats Instagram
I told Cassie get ready cuz you begin a
bunch I've actually haven't gotten one
yet which I'm very heavy well now it's
over they just fell now yeah it's coming
from Bryan Callen
a giant dick and he goes do you like to
be dominated I was like if you listen to
the podcast to know that I'm not into
guys but I mean well know if he does the
guys yeah don't assume you but I but I
was like oh you rats on that tank Oh
chin Jay had your back when me and Brian
were making funny for the airdrop but
he's like who don't have your drop on
I'm like Lena Brian don't Jay goes
everyone in like in his business on zero
drop on you know Jason you know the
impossible head he's in this impossible
sweaty head shut up to Jason he's my boy
I I SH for impossible sweaty head yes
he's just sweats like in the middle of
the winter like it you know it's
terrible like the worst sweat you've
ever seen he comes out of the sauna
you're like Jesus Christ man anyways he
anyway
he has his ear drop on he said people do
it all the time on the subway in New
York and people just drop dick pics now
you say you have no and he goes it's the
one of the fun things to do just sit on
the subway and click accept and get dick
pics and guys [ __ ] girls he goes it's
awesome why why why my ear drops on your
ear drops on you just pick it up off of
people's phones random people it's a you
know Larry the [ __ ] winner problem
course you have naked pictures of
yourself on your phone only if you do it
though all if you want to jump you know
to them they do it to you
they'll see Brian's phones nearby
they'll drop a picture and you there's
always a previously there's no way you
can't see the bring it except then
you've got this fat [ __ ] and your phone
that's great hilarious I don't know
who's like you know you would baby I bet
some hot girls like out though freak and
you're like whose is this yeah career
drop this yes
but yeah J was like no everyone has
their [ __ ] ear drop on do you count I
don't know somebody once tried to air
drop me their number I had no idea who
it was I was like in the middle of
campus walking out like who the [ __ ]
it was a tight moves though I feel like
but I don't know part move you didn't
send me the photo though if he say his
photo maybe he bows sterno number yeah
that's so I had to turn it off I was
like he should have sent a picture fall
by his number oh if I get some dick dick
pics by anybody I usually send them
another dick pic that I find on the
Internet
hilarious that's my go-to like thank you
for your dick pic that's when you watch
the other one did I tell you I was at my
buddy Jerry McFadden's house and I had
to I said you know what it's 11:00 at
night but if I got if I walk and I walk
through Central Park at night I'll get
to where I need to go faster how long
ago is this this was the last time I was
in New York okay and I made the mistake
of putting it into my google maps and it
took me right through the the rambles
which is a forested area of Central Park
yeah really scary I was actually scared
yeah chief I was very scary you don't
wanna do that mainly it's also where all
the gay men meet up and you don't want
to get bit they walk around alone and
they [ __ ] each other now think about
11:00 at night I'm walking through
although alone scared the [ __ ] out of me
actually home on two really good scare
one too cuz back in the day you'd get
killed you would never do that ever
values can get [ __ ] yes you don't want a
homeless guy biting you who knows you
don't want to hear that no homeless guys
biting you know no strange men who spent
too much time at the gym you know
banging you with their friends did you
see anything there you go did you see
anything or did you I saw that I saw
plenty of men who were looking at me yes
and they were all hanging out and did
what you see they're just in the bushes
[ __ ] they're looking at you like I
look at pie
yep and they were like you're the guy
from the Goldbergs I'm MADtv perhaps
like I was and they were like what are
you doing here and I go well I was
walking home but now I'm confused
there you go that's what you see a lot
no I swear to God I swear to God
that's what you see a lot of so did you
make like dog I used to see in see this
is it was quite a story though bro did
you make it out what do you see anything
made it out alive I made it out of life
I made it out alive
but I felt like this nothing that but
that's the only difference there was a
side effect a part like this
um whom I know I made I made it out
alive but I used to run my dog patty
Jenkins when I was we were hanging out
and she
pitbull I would take the pimple to the
rambles the problem with taking your
pimple to the rambles off-leash is
there's a lot of those and your dog eats
them condoms uh-huh
your dog eats uh gay used condoms and
then poos them out she dug hid so I
stopped taking my dog to the rambles and
also when you take your dog the rambles
do you have any what is eating you and
you happen across lots of men who are
doing things so I saw a lot of that so I
stopped going to the rambles and I never
would do this but I said to the cop I go
I don't care but it's kind of a pain in
the ass that I got to walk through there
and it's literally just littered with
dudes coupling up and they're commenting
you're gonna hate don't get me started
don't get me started I was like man
that's just a common place to [ __ ]
yes it's always been a gay holds you I
was in Utah uh and I was in the bathroom
in the stall and dude did this with his
foot no yeah two down he gives you a
triple tap I thought man he's looking to
[ __ ] how strive rushed out of there
yeah but I always thought these three
taps like is this a murder thing is this
a dicksuck thing that's how they caught
that congressman that Senator in the
airport and he had been responsible for
anti-gay legislation what a surprise
hypocrite yeah I have nothing dude that
I like I don't know what happened it was
like this it's very but it also too it's
like you know your feet are like this
reinstall it's over here and going and
then you put your dog through the glory
hole yeah now I put my mouth through
first like a tongue anyone in there oh
the answers they're talking to the mic
oh no we've been this is my way oh yeah
it's been a very gay theme day yeah it
has I don't know why did you bring it
out of me man sorry hi yeah yeah chop it
like a [ __ ] did you ever fight
anybody thank my dad that made a lot of
noise when they were punching nope never
really hone does nope never
nope you never did nope get some current
events Jin yeah cats got some before we
get any gayer what do you guys got
so a Tino was caught distributing
cookies at school and her grandfather's
ashes were baked into them why did she
well apparently her I'm sure mom had
some dude was right she just didn't do
it or this is high school this is a high
school student some students knew before
Hannah still consumed Dakota yeah about
nine students ate it there are a couple
who didn't know I don't know I wouldn't
care I mean I know weird well I was at a
balut but you you eat a cookie with much
rather eat seven people ground up in
cookies in balut they they're trying to
figure out what the Penal Code is for
plot baking human rape remain I'll come
but there are ashes
yeah they don't know what to charge her
with um how about I I was at Saltonstall
you stay in you know they have their are
they have like their special flavors in
October we have human finger ice cream
I wish fingernails no but they have
ground-up bugs grasshoppers and
mealworms chocolate-covered come on like
a perfume they also have pig's blood ice
cream what and then they had another one
that's called real pigs bug now yeah
type in salt & straw yeah yeah
gelatinous big boy that's pig's blood
you like polite it's called Dracula
'some my coagulated blood yeah oh that's
why I danced on the weekend the course
nervous runny
do you like coagulated blood he's our
Union he likes our african-american who
regulate it blood where a dim sum
yeah he cubed blood it with tripe that's
tough it's amazing not in amazing I
don't drink that I feel sick
well I can't need this I can't I can't
eat ice cream day I got there cherry and
smoked bone marrow ice cream and I even
bone marrow makes me feel sick oh no you
uh it's just go to all don't go images
there goes creepy crawlers critters salt
& straw blood and bug ice cream scroll
down you can't tell right go up chin cuz
that's where the description I think
yeah single grasshopper and then they
have they have one with the blood yeah
thanks but they have one called candy
topia and it's butterscotch ice cream
with Twix Snickers and Reese's in it it
will change your [ __ ] life I've ever
had in my life
the only asking I've liked better from
them is they had a Lucky Charms ice
cream where it's all just marshmallows
from Lucky Charms
and vanilla ice cream really my son does
really nice came by took him there and
he went nuts on it track his blood
pudding there it is mmm [ __ ] click on
that bro let me educate you can't he
talks how I read that ice creams merely
crafted for this year's Halloween
thrill-seekers no Hannah no holds barred
this is the most inducting we've
measured into real blood pudding with a
hint of chicken liver and sponsor on ice
cream laboratory and they get it from my
fruit somewhere in the blood to pay it's
pig's blood [ __ ] I bet you like eating
it I'm not trying joana tried the bugs
ones I'll try the bugs no problem no not
me but blood see this this is amazing
that's [ __ ] damn blood that's blood
stomach lining right there
that's right mmm out of all the shitty
chin you need that who got a tasty
nothing
Julia I've never tried it liar that
looks like dog never tried that looks
like just like dog food I'm sure I ate
that stuff when I was in China but I ate
a bunch of stuff like that I was like
what is this know if it's slimy and
squared I don't eat it bro Chinese food
I'm not eating frogs I'm not eating
blood I don't not that exotic ready from
frog seems like chicken bullfrog though
they they do I could eat a whole [ __ ]
thing I don't like the stomach sense
dude that's disgusting look at the
description my favorite my favorite what
the smiley faces what else you got Jim
take your pork blood so that washed me
outside girl yes no I was gonna ask you
what what religion outlaws the drinking
or consuming of pig blood blood in
general idea not Satanism they could
they can donate
it's not Dracul ism Satanism dude I saw
Satan and I missed his hoe test of
Satanists outside and they had a little
[ __ ] baby
the lady was holding the baby and he had
devil horns I'm like you [ __ ] it yeah
anyway um who can doesn't condone it
who's who does not allow you to drink
Buddhist no although Buddha's
technically don't that Buddha's
technically if you're a Buddhist you
don't kill any that being so I thought
the answer is Jews and Muslims Muslims
don't pay in the Book of Leviticus I
believe it is here one of the dietary
restrictions is yesterday's blood
because blood you can get very sick from
it a lot of those dietary restrictions
were put in place because you it's kept
you from getting really bad pathogens
what else yet can they you know do you
guys remember the cache me outside girl
hell yeah so I'm a thing had cyborgs in
her latest music video with why do with
yg yeah he's on with yg play this for me
chin
it's called juice so she's huge you know
what and some of her songs aren't bad
she's killing it Theo was in her last
video she's huge huge two million video
views on this already she's very young
so we can't really Thomas ate on her
looks she's a white girl who wants to be
black so bad but is she white Spanish no
she's white as they came really yeah
we've talked about how she got famous
pretty pretty hair John dr. Phil she's
something special though yeah there's
some about her she's she's doing well
I'll see she's not writing songs but she
definitely has something going for I'm
not mad at her at all she's cute how old
is she thank you so much she's like 16
17 years old she's crazy like a fox is
what she is crazy talented yes we're sad
were coming this thing white side were
gone here I don't know why cyber was it
was in the music video but she's in a
few clips back and forth
she turned this into something really a
time boy just catch cyborg in it
mmm-hmm
right there [ __ ] just kind of chillin oh
oh she's Hazzard just chill in the video
yeah I have no idea how they linked up
but oh she says it like shadowboxing
yeah I think she just kind of has this
backup that's pretty cool though yeah
that little girl's killing it though man
mm-hmm she's a matter bad billionaire
for sure yeah yeah
milling it easily just off for YouTube
yeah she's crazy
oh that's that silent that Truscott
sicko mode let me see it that's my
[ __ ] I can't get it I just play it
non-stop now 13 million views is that
good yeah
two days ago - came out two days ago
long and short shot Lia's pity bull
Brian you want the phone
that's kylie jenner's man and baby daddy
his face could also stop a clock place
he's not the most handsome dude in the
world makes a great Jam I'm looking at
his teeth oh the golden bullet when them
teeth well that's your pop culture
education for the day yo you know those
kids can't stop it you all right well
that's called psycho mode mm-hmm I'm
always saying I'm sure it's interesting
I don't I'll try to look up the lyrics
you love that song those are very
different generation oh yeah you're into
shoes and rap huh oh yeah dude what else
you get in so um somebody DM to me this
article there's a hospital in Toronto
that just released a assisted suicide
plan for kids and one of the policies is
that if the kids do not want to notify
their parents of this the hospital
cannot legally alert the parents that
this is happening I don't I don't
believe this article actually have been
see
in news group of medics from Toronto
released a shocking paper which outlines
its controversial is not child
euthanasia and paper in some cases the
young person's parents will not be
notified of the intention in their own
lives until after the death is confirmed
yeah this hasn't gone through yet this
is a proposal yeah yeah that's pretty
either way too interesting yes well
because it goes back to when you're a
kid and you you go to Planned Parenthood
and you ask for contraception the
question is should parents be told that
your kids don't give your condoms with a
pill and it's a I think it's a
case-by-case state-by-state baby
remember dr. Kevorkian yeah
well I do was helping people commit
suicide yeah he wasn't a bad dude no
they blocked him away for a long time
well yeah he but he was ending people
helping people who had terrible pain or
we're gonna die anyway and and people
who were never gonna walk again and one
day and yeah he did in a very and I
think you know I think he provided an
amazing service I agree that's a thing
is ridiculous I totally agree I think as
an adult you should be allowed to end
your own life for you how we're gonna
how long did he go to a doctor Kevorkian
good luck spell mention
that's okay Evi I played him others I
played him on MADtv yeah did you might
be able to pull it up I'm wearing up all
the way let me see how long he's going
away for though wait says speak sec time
really nice 10 to 25 died two years
eight years of 2025 he was a brave guy
man he fought it all the way he said
this is about quality of life and he
would show up in the middle of the night
with his team and they they do it he was
a real badass show up in the middle of
night oh I had to watch I had to watch a
lot of tapes of them cuz I played him on
MADtv bring that up the four hours away
come but doc man what a Jim Carrey this
one dr. Kiley no yeah type in Bryan
Callen
mmm there it is that it reads I'm Joe
Rogan though we've seen that one on here
twice we see if it's not on YouTube
maybe oh yeah yeah let me check it let
Jim I don't see it he shows one aired
you're in the forum it's all good all
right
either way dr. Kevorkian did some [ __ ]
yeah and I think that he added a good
service I think that if you want to end
your life you should be allowed to not
as exchange but it's your own ass adult
who's like if you're terminally ill or
something like that or you just don't
want to do it like it's your choice but
I'm blowing your brains out or hanging
yourself somebody finds you or whatever
it might be I don't know what else you
got
so it a frat party it was thrown for
Clemson University at an apartment
complex and everybody there was jumping
dancing partying so hard for homecoming
that the floor went out under them and a
collapse and they got it on video you
and I know people were injured nobody
had any life-threatening injuries but
it's just this is it here yeah that's a
lot of people yeah that's a slow video
oh [ __ ]
celebration turns to terror in Clemson
South Carolina what happened and I would
like people were injured when the floor
to the basement amazingly no one was
trapped and no one suffered any light
was underneath it took minutes for
firefighters to get there god damn I got
there quick and I mean I did see like
people because we were kids stories
Clemson police Oh both of the arteries
we're broken probably in a suit well if
there's a capacity thing they could be
in charge gets sued over that no one got
hurt what else you guys got you got
insurance do you guys remember a little
take a little
yeah badass like she's a badass but
badass like she's just she would you
bring her up so Brian gasps contract I
know she will the listeners be able to
see your chin or no I mean will the
viewers BLC on instagram yeah I'll show
lil turns on YouTube to marry her dad
hover like with the money and [ __ ] yeah
is her mom mm-hmm is her mom and her
older brother so this is just an example
[Music]
[Music]
watching she's she's a good little
actress yeah this she do so much more -
so what happened - so she disappeared
from social media for a couple months
and nobody knew what happened to her
everybody assumed that since her mom and
her brother got so much backlash over
helping her make these videos that they
thought they just took her off of social
media her social media went back live
about two days ago with several posts
and whoever's posting on it is saying
that the reason why she has been m.i.a
is because her dad ended up getting
custody of her and won't let her post
these videos yeah it goes a little
it goes a little weird or her father was
basically a deadbeat left her and her
mom when she was a kid never paid child
support the mom would have to take the
dad to court to even pay any of it but
once he found out that she was getting
famous and found out that the mom and
the brother were getting in trouble for
all these videos he took them to court
to get custody of Lotte there's a video
Lotte crying saying that she didn't want
to go back because when he used to take
care of her when she was younger he
would leave her with his new wife's
sister who was a teenager at the time
didn't like Lotte would lock her in the
closet for an hour's walk they would
make her watch scary movies even though
she was she would be crying she wouldn't
want to watch it and there's also
accounts of her father bringing her on
two trips with girls I he would have
affairs with while is he married to her
mother and they would have sex in the
same bed as her those are reports right
those are reports that's what's
happening on her Instagram right now so
people are kind of going nuts about
what's happening to Lotte we don't know
if this is real or not she's huge yeah
yeah you see her cry and suddenly feel
so well they're very young they're
they're not is this idea that she knows
has perspective on anything or she's no
their children and in every sense of the
word well ever since
well it's good that dad's a piece of
[ __ ]
kids kids some kids have real trouble
with chaos and when they don't know
what's going on though they it's really
interesting because psychologically kids
need their own autonomy and their own
power and if they don't get it if they
if they're either completely disciplined
or they're growing up in chaos they will
create their own they'll create their
own and sometimes it's in the form of
total defiance and being a complete
[ __ ] because at least they can control
that at least that gives them an
identity you know don't be shitty
parents it's more of the story don't be
a [ __ ] yeah but even sometimes be like
they'll the new psychology it's the
parents that really are really really
disciplined with our kids that doesn't
work for some kids no you don't give
them some air to breathe and make their
own choices art that's one
so this came out today Sarah Silverman
talks about how she allowed louis c.k to
masturbate in front of her Wow
I don't know exactly why she came out
with it cuz throughout the article she
says that she doesn't agree with what he
did in terms of masturbating in front of
other women without their consent
and that he was building his power
against them but then she also goes in
to a story about how they did a
cross-country road trip and she accounts
that she allowed him to masturbate in
front of her 20 times I just thought
that was a very specific I know Laura
that she came masturbated in front of
her I've worked at Laura approximately
20 times during a cross-country trip
before he was famous awhile she said
when we were kids he asked if he could
masturbate in front of me sometimes go
[ __ ] yeah let's see that Wow Wow
and we were nothing more we're just
friends so sometimes yeah I want to see
it it was amazing sometime say [ __ ]
no gross and we get went and got pizza
yeah how [ __ ] up again yeah yeah
that's just thing that's clearly his
thing she was honest and what he did was
a chemist at a certain point when he
became influential not even famous but
influential in the world of comedy it
changes I couldn't pass statements he
felt like he was the same person but the
dynamic was different it was not okay
Wow
I believe he has remorse I just want to
make him talk about it on stage he's
going to have to find a way or not find
its way
it's so weird she jacked off about 20
times that criminal like component a
compulsive brooding gray no weird is
this in question I just keep asking
myself can you love someone who did bad
things can you still love him
sure of course you can you know yeah for
sure you know because you're not all
human beings are not all one thing where
everything sometimes you have a bad side
you have a good side I mean depends
just stop jacking off for people then
yeah that's a thing maybe just that's a
weird thing can you get another thing
instead of that thing so also by the way
I know I know some of these women like I
know some of them like like they're not
there they're comic
in there they could they hang out and
they're working with you and it's not
like you it'd be like it's just so weird
it's it'd be like what do you brought
this he's part of our group yeah but
this is they she's hanging out with us
we're all friends and we're all on the
same thing together
yeah no Jack what are you doing Jack
tada
hey do you mind if I jerk off running
huh why what do you want to do can i
film it what do you want me to do just
stand and watch so who needs a foyer
personally I do it alone even if you
paid I bet even they start paying
hookers you went like it it's not as
dangerous right I guess this is free
maybe that's what it is I don't [ __ ]
get it what else you guys got the
Hyperloop is supposed to come out
December 10th
what is Hyperloop remember that
underground tunnel are you talking about
the subway but no but these things go
hard 55 miles per hour I'm not a fast
train so they're gonna be testing and if
it works out well this could change
everything they still have to build the
tunnels him no they have the yet he said
the first tunnel is complete we did that
yesterday on December 10 yeah but how
big is it at least two miles long right
now yeah well if you want to get tested
just a test you want to get to it in two
miles and 20 if you wanna go from here
to Whole Foods we can do it underground
yeah I guess who's been just digging all
over torrents and [ __ ] underneath so
it's in Hawthorne I know oh it's gonna
be in Hawthorne yeah yeah that's where
uh mm-hmm
the first time is almost done it's like
two miles long I think I read the field
I mean we joke around must be a [ __ ]
nightmare cause of earthquake and all
that stuff it will be as little as one
dollar it could be as low as one dollar
traffic is driving me nuts all right
bill the tunnel boring machine and just
start digging that's December 17 2016 I
think he said something on Rogen about
it being a long way off or maybe maybe
being impossible but he just wants to do
it anyway you know he was saying they
bet they've been digging it he like
they've been digging all over there's
holes all over yeah you've got it you've
got to go through I mean it's it's a
that's a state
why'd you know sort of collaboration of
legislation and everything else to miles
though I like that that's just me oh
yeah one kilometer that's yeah what is
that 2.2 mosque okay all right sit one
kilometer
one kilometer it's less than that it's
point five miles point six miles no time
I should not even look at that point six
miles point six two miles no but that's
a that's a competition that's not his
thing the pros truck with three
kilometers in the lane you're saying the
proposed district yeah that's the one
that's the door now well it seems that
we do have to figure out something about
all the cars and the lack of
infrastructure so you don't you're going
down a weird road right now Jen why
either way it's gonna be it's gonna be
cool yeah it will be in 30 years
now what I'm 68 there's gonna be flying
cars and you're still going under yeah
that's right how would you make a flying
car bro
I know hit the year [ __ ] going below
city here talked about that Elon talked
about that it would you say though the
city would be just be too freaking loud
because of the freakin propellers yep
you need like little drones I don't come
up with something without propellers
hey you you come on he talked about
magnets they talked about magnets -
that's a possibility
magnets now the time at tubes oh yeah
that the master was for the Lear at the
bank we don't bank and put in them you
go booth and then they would get it
right there - that's how the thing works
yeah it's a hard pass [ __ ] hard pass
hey did you guys you guys take the sulk
hey where's the spoon what else you guys
get stung this one another hot teacher
had sex with a 14 year old student she's
gonna face a minimum of five years jail
I'll take her at that Park put on a
house arrest for in my in my that poor
kid what'd she do suck his dick yeah and
sent pictures naked pictures oh wow but
come on the [ __ ] you wanna see a
picture fool
oh my God look at that yeah what the
[ __ ] is going on look at that I'll put
her in jail no can we talk about this
[ __ ] of that fish there's any other
pictures that song was a show the main
very attractive you should definitely go
to her Instagram I would help her out I
could dress up like a 14 year old dude
you can I'll take you fishing yeah yeah
I mean I'd never had that 14 or I was
fine I bet he's all shook up I bet he's
all I want to do it 14 so the mother's
the one that wanted to report it that's
the reason why they got caught yeah damn
it mom yeah why shouldn't get all the
right dad you know that hot teacher you
saw on back to school and I my guys like
she suck my dick I'm like we're going to
the cops now I am like fist bump
hyah sizzling there is something
probably psychologically off with her
that she would take that risk and you
have to know that you're gonna baby oh
it's awesome 14-year old he's captain of
the football team
huge dick and he's awesome he's like
real mature yeah or not she's probably
pretty [ __ ] up with a full beard yeah
I wish we could see the kids they will
never do that no I'd love to analyze
they'll surprise you if I got like a
full beard yeah they're like LeBron
James I'd like to be if I can let's see
LeBron James when he was 14 there a guy
there are some athletes out there that
are he never has ever this just you know
with teachers well we know that video
from forever yeah I guess that song
looks pretty young there anyway there's
nothing to do with this what else yeah
that was random what else you got there
he is right there it looks young [ __ ]
our teens very young so there's just an
update on that girl not this one this
one remember that girl that would unless
be the neighbor into the apartment she'd
held the door oh yeah and be super
racist yeah last week you watched it
that was Leslie grant
so this is her reasoning and she does
she's not backing down from it too
so get up huh should you beat up no I
saw a girl the black guy well that's a
different man inside Friday night has
hit social media and gone viral as woman
in the video says he didn't have a key
fob to get in and forced his way inside
she reached out to me to tell her side
of the story after being called a racist
and receiving death threats it's an
exclusive interview you will see only on
Fox 2 tonight Fox 2 into my building
racist so when I noticed an individual
that I did not know my only intent was
to follow the direction that I had been
given by her condo association board
members so deadly and that is to never
allow access to any individual they wore
black thornton showed us several emails
from the association stating what
residents should do when dealing with a
situation like this Hillary says Dorian
said he was trying to get into the
building as she had to door cracks fair
as her dog went to the bathroom and I
simply asked if he lived there he said
yeah because the direction from the
condo association is so repeated that if
you don't know the person you do not let
them in Thornton had she told him she
couldn't let him in then asked if he had
a key fob the only indicator that any
resident has that they live in that
building he would not answer me he would
not show me one she says that if he had
one he could have used it to get in and
wouldn't have needed her to let him in
did he force his way in there was an
altercation at the front door and that's
how he got into the building do we see
that on video you do not the camera was
pointed at the ground but you hear me
say something along the lines of oh my
gosh are you serious
to which he replied go ahead and call
the place you see my he's in the door
she followed him to his room until she
realized he had door keys to get into
the room after the video went viral her
company Tribeca stl fired her for racial
profiling they do not own the property
where this occurred she says she has had
death threats as well when you're called
a racist how does that make you feel
that is you better cry girl absolutely
false and heartbreaking and those are
words that truly cut deep authority for
it legally married to an
african-american man says oh she's
racist she married to a black did she
say that right now - she doesn't have -
Wow no were to help her cause I think
she's just she's just one of those
people just doesn't know how to react to
a situation and get into my building
black quite a lot of carries and he
doesn't have a fob nah I can understand
you not getting in I don't know where
she lives but she's married to a black
dude I'm sorry so that's pretty none
that's pretty anti race a white why
wouldn't that come out right away though
why would she like my husband's black
what the [ __ ] we talking about here
that's her like oh yeah I'm like oh now
we're all like oh sorry sorry she's come
on man which was funny cuz he actually
came out and he said that he stood with
the man that she stopped he like yeah
what she did wasn't right also I don't
live with her anymore he like trying to
distance himself from her as much as
possible you know he's under pressure
too now because of the public square but
at least that's interesting
oh he's interesting very interesting I
like that so that beaten up girl have
you seen this video before about a big
dude and a small chicken into a fight no
so I'd rather do you guys just watch
this and see what happens this man beats
petite woman in parking lot mm-hmm
holy [ __ ] that's it I'll just watch the
video here where's it's at first of all
Texas okay so this truck right here is
waiting to get in this parking lot hope
she goes okay whoo right in there he
gets out see I wouldn't get out I got
you little [ __ ] especially man this is
the driver well I hope you wouldn't get
out and beat her up Brad
the driver is the Maul of this other
little girls lost you can see he's
complaining about the parking and she
says you can find out other open spots
and then she walks away
all right and I did that guy now the
daughter comes out all the brisket in
Texas your daughter the right to access
your car but look at the daughter oh no
damn no bad punch my bad punch Brian
yeah yeah oh becomes mom oh [ __ ]
oh girl came back I got oh damn that guy
[ __ ] rag I mean obviously 300 pounds
she's still coming back for more she's
got balls for sure
good fair
kick this car good sir Jesus Christ man
yeah
anyhow that's that girl right now oh but
the thing is a lot of people are getting
on her well she threw the first yeah he
kicked her car she threw the first punch
but as a grown man you can't don't even
if a girl punch correct he can't really
beat the [ __ ] out she can't do that
though just don't shoot yeah yeah but
the problem is here's where he gets off
that right here's the big promise is she
can't do that and then not expect
someone to recount exactly yeah cuz he
has to defend himself now I didn't have
to beat the brakes off you and then
spike you on the ground he does she's
also very attractive yes he does get off
though doesn't hate for that I don't
think the [ __ ] mom came at him
terrible didn't hit him no we don't know
cuz I'm the video you don't know but I
can tell you this I was gonna say she
came right up to him and he was
self-defense and he pushed her away and
and hot she looks like she needs help
with she's adorable she's adorable I
could yeah she's a beautiful woman
I don't do private no figured out you
could teach her some I'm in she drew a
good punch that looked like she threw
her body into it probably hit him good
thought let me see it let me see it yeah
I'm sick let me break it down do I mean
break it the hell you watch this alright
here you go watch this ready ready oh
that's not a bad punch tonight is bad
all right it's great tech news now it
didn't really make it wasn't very good
technique because it didn't really stop
oh he just threw her
'we see that ghetto let's see i think
thats validate where he's throwing her
the promised way throws the mom is
raising you in trouble yeah - look she
just came around - she he reacted she
threw that rewind again - you know what
the mom came at him
she came at him dude he walks I'm
telling you he walks does it that's two
times she's attacked him by the way if
it be he oh you know what he's getting
you're troubling one [ __ ] up the cop
know that hit that's not can I tell you
why so you're allowed this is gonna
sound like a crazy rule if you kick
someone's car including if you kick
someone's dog because your dog is
property if you shoot somebody because
they're bashing your dog over the head
right on video I know you shot him you
would go to jail because that would be
property so actually but here in some if
you damn its owns you're not allowed to
you add you are 100% not allowed to then
attack his I'm not sayin attack no no no
no what I'm saying is he's getting in
trouble for damaging their car
not for fight if it was damaged he just
kicked it right so but but she'll got so
right now if a 300-pound man donkey
kicks your car there's gonna damn it
well because that's not relevant cuz she
she's the one actually who has to like
for a night what I'm saying go no I'm
not the bomb I'm saying is he's gonna
have to pay for the car he's not getting
double for whooping Iraq his problems
can become from damaging property I
don't think he'd I don't think he he
wasn't arrested but it's it's being
investigated so he might just have to
cover the door yeah correct there's a
dent
I mean 300-pound man donkey kicks your
door it's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up donkey they
get that kick man they can be pretty bad
you I didn't see the kick oh my gosh see
the kick he said three analyze the cat
mule look how big he is he's a big boy
yes some athletic shoes on now cargo
can't believe this he looks around goes
oh oh that's a good kid not bad okay I
didn't see that he throws her into that
he didn't need to do the second third
way he's a he's a woman Peter he's a bad
guy he pushes really sexy and kinky he
just whooped her ass and even think
about it
she's a stocky little thing he's got
some hips on her she does she's an
amateur fighter chin she does is either
trains that I've made or she's an MMA
fighter well she wasn't scared of that
dude
cute little she's pretty we gotta find
out how old she is my my both father and
daughter high ranking martial arts
instructor Australia they're doubting my
martial arts that's not what I'm trained
to do I'm not trained to go hurt people
we know how to fight but we don't look
for that that's not what the martial
arts is about so the guy was big he's
300 on the hair and threw her against a
wall so yeah oh did you see that video
will sasso sent me those two guys who
try to fight that tank it's great yeah
and those two guys are like kind of
built like me and they're like let's
beat this guy up and he goes oh yeah let
me tackle both of you
I can throw what else you got do you see
the Samoan kid with the two white kids
so we done I think that sometime thought
about the grown man and Russia fighting
three other fighters oh no I'm seeing
you time mother small Thomas moaning kid
is he Samoan yeah don't fight us Aaron
oh it's great you said two kids against
both of them and runs them plenty hawks
out oh yeah I think Barstow said like
calling Nick Saban calling Nick Saban
because he like perfect double legs them
getting thrown you know hip tossed on
cement I think that's the one dude gets
no no J showed it to me I didn't see it
sasso sent it to me and said that's
Chris that's you and Bryant Rana it's
hilarious though he beats the [ __ ] out
of them yeah
and kicks the guy yeah it's on a
bathroom wall no - nope it's a parking
lot and the mom comes out yeah cuz he's
beating the [ __ ] out of both of them
yeah oh well yeah I don't see it alright
what else we got I didn't see the guy in
Russia
that you just beat the share these guys
one guy just move on chin there's too
many videos alright so the way they
killed off Roseanne on now the Connors
show was an opioid overdose so that how
did the ratings do so that's another
thing that happen nothing close to what
so debuted at ten point 10.5 million
viewers and two point three rating among
adults 18 to 49 that's fifty five
percent down but then the last episode
with Roseanne was kind of around that
area yeah they were dead like only but
that's the thing we're compared to the
debut yeah he's higher but the average
of Roseanne's this isn't that bad so one
Roseanne the last show with Roseanne was
ten point three million and two point
forwarding so it's just just the way
we're doing now is ten point five I
don't know is 10.5 good for that that's
still good yeah is that solid when
Roseanne returned last March still very
solid star again it was only eighteen
point two minutes something like those
four that's a lot though eighteen point
to mind staggering in today's world with
so many choices for sure crazy ratings
that's crazy ratings it's actually huge
oh yeah oh yeah so is but ten millions
good with today's ratings right yes it
was a hit when you get ten still hit no
matter what because most you tomorrow
most of these shows I Amazon's up they
get curious to see what Netflix does if
so many you to keep it a secret but but
you know a lot of these shows that get
ten episodes and stuff like that I mean
the actors on those shows have a tough
time making a living well cuz you have
no idea yeah they're not sure they like
making them who gets some money for
making a murderer seaman Avery does it
right because you can't who gets all
that money I don't know who's making
murder - I think I bloody Netflix buys
your rights right yeah it buys the show
so what Netflix does typically is if you
make a movie for a Netflix you're a
production team they'll say here's eight
million dollars go make your movie and
then we're gonna make whatever you make
you know so the movie cost you five you
get
two three you know you present a budget
to them and they'll give you the money
but so the other laugh and TVs the same
way the question of what sowho like with
Steven Avery they're covering the story
they're doing all this so my guess on
that is that the producers came to them
with this this documentary and sold it
to Netflix or or go to Steven Avery so
that's the thing so it was either his
estate whoever channels his account his
money they would have to get his
permission right yeah but that the life
rights are not expensive Rises I can
even get paid from them you buy the life
rights and then you would have liked to
own at all the Netflix would probably
buy it for a salary right so so they
would buy it from the producers so it's
very it's very likely that Steven Avery
got a one-time fee though what you see
playing out maker murder was not unique
to the story these things happen every
day all right okay that there's nothing
for us okay no but then part two it's
like woohoo like obviously it's such
they work video ever they worked out a
deal I'm sure so they went to Netflix
and said I'm sure if they're smart they
said hey we want to make making a murder
too and Netflix said here's 30 million
dollars or whatever it is we get the
rights to it you understand and that's
what I just wonder where the money goes
it's a good question I think it belongs
to the penguin it is public domain after
he's arrested and they shadowed each of
them yes with them right so not all his
footage so when they do it they buy your
life right they're enjoying it
his family so what you do you do is you
go I want to buy your life right so I
want to buy the rights yeah you can buy
those for 25 grand but the--but season
two they couldn't write because you like
no it's not I'm sure I'm sure if he had
a good lawyer if somebody was like yeah
yeah I'd be interested where that money
goes that well use all those legal fees
gets paid for they're all making money
now yeah anyways what else you got I
think that's gonna be it yeah like
really about this
oh okay Wow
so when they do like that that the
documentary was at staircase like that
guy opened up like his entire life to
them interviews they wear cameras with
them all the time yeah that would be I
wonder how much they get paid you're
making money for that you know yeah I
don't know wait I'll show you guys one
thing that I thought was cool but if
it's ever like that last one please
don't know this order is just a random
fight at a rap concert but look at this
woman beat up this other woman that's
all I can say right oh what a big girl
that's a big big girl holy [ __ ] she's
swinging she's a big woman this throw
ended no this she continues she runs up
on her attacks or more god damn a big
guy anyways that was just for that big
girl I'd like to see her fight that fat
guy that girl that's the fight worldstar
yeah that's what that is why you never
want to fight somebody as big as will
sasso or if you're me cuz he pick you up
and throw you all you do that yeah like
if he gets mad he's gonna he's gonna go
he's gonna he's gonna gorilla you will
mad though no but I promise you will
would get mad if they have you ever
seemed like no yeah I've seen him yeah
yeah and and if will I feel like will
would be really hard to hurt if he was
really angry yeah he's like giant like
I'm sure use like jug enough yeah that's
my gift I'm sure you've sparred with
guys who you hit him in the face when
they're heated and it's like they would
usually drop a regular guy and when
they're really big like that no we'll
see yeah well that that that one thing
where you're in the middle of the fight
with cro cop and he breaks your nose
yeah he punches you really hard that's a
I don't know if you know this but cro
cop can punch hard and he's a trained
fighter and she'll fight yeah I will
Seth and and no but still I'm saying
that the human body when you're really
amped up and your Adrenaline's going you
think you took a full punch to face bro
Kano's and you kind of smiled at him was
my job I'm just saying that that when
you're a big guy and you're in the
middle of a fight and your adrenaline
spiked you know it's it's hard to hurt
somebody they'll pick you up and throw
you on your [ __ ] head like that you
see that a lot on YouTube like giant
people who pick up records today any
technique just wait a little bit but he
just don't you see his calves so he
looks like he does lift yeah yeah well
that's it unless you want break down a
little fighting technique for no but use
them music gable grip big guys just left
alright perfect dude I think that's it
dude that's it buddy
that's it I'm gonna go box right now
please do and we're gonna technique
horse in the report back Photoshop Steve
over G Gnaeus Photoshop Steve these are
[ __ ] hilarious
he sent them to you chillin yeah they
came frame he's amazing yeah they're so
holy he cracks me up
so you're cracking up Brian you're
coming with me to San Francisco cos I am
Friday Saturday that went November 3rd
2nd and 3rd that would meet me kind of
signaling the chin to bring up my dates
what he zoning out so you've only done
300 shows together what can you do
so we got cobs November 2nd it was under
comin with me we got up cobs this
Saturday when Phoenix though Oh this
Saturday we all think Jody festival you
me re big J Theo
that's kind of Fame show I forget a
sold-out [ __ ] all that keep at kcon
44 Brian and I at Cobb San Francisco
let's give me [ __ ] dude to weakens their
weak to hang I know
adventures Sacramento you are there
11:16
much live in 17 at the punchline then
you're at Gotham comedy club
November 30th and December 1st hit him
with the big one if I had any decency
I'd go to you I'd go with that one to
you with you I know and you got New
Mexico that's an inch December 7 rooted
down there never been there you intently
and [ __ ] my pants Santa Fe is a magical
place I think
doing that and then you got San Diego
we're gonna shoot your Showtime special
get your tickets one 1919 that'd be
January 19th Spreckels theater you got
some San Diego those tickets are a boom
in we've got some special guests opening
up that night
t f-- @k calm for tickets also this
wednesday the vintage firing the kids
street fighter shirts and Sesame Street
Bert and Ernie firing the kid collab
drops Wednesday 5:00 p.m. Pacific t fat
k calm get your tickets for all my shows
and I will see you guys around
this is the fine kid we're out